are you tired of gaming in boring old 4k
well this sucks
i could barely even make out the
individual pixels
how am i even gonna know it's a video
game
are you tired of having all that extra
money in your wallet
introducing the new rtx 2060 the more
expensive version of the gtx 1160 we
accidentally leaked a few weeks ago now
you can play all your compatible games
at half the frame rate
buy now
awesome
and you know what else is awesome our
sponsor for this video glasswire with
glasswire you can instantly see your
current and past network activity detect
malware and block badly behaving apps on
your pc or android device use offer code
linus to get 25 off below
all kidding aside we've been pretty
negative about product releases from
nvidia lately and while it's good to get
our frustrations out every once in a
while it gets pretty boring if
everything is crap you know so for this
review
i'm going to give the rtx 2060 every
chance i can for it to impress me and
i'm gonna try not to think too much
about my problems with the rest of the
rtx launches
and
that should be pretty easy on paper this
thing actually has a lot going for it
compared to the gtx 1060 it's got more
cuda cores and way faster memory uh that
is depending on which version of the
card you get more on that later and
that's to say nothing of the inclusion
of the usb type-c based virtual link
connector in fact the rtx 2060 looks
more like a beefed up gtx 1070
which is great because it's priced that
way too okay all right sorry i'm letting
a little bit of salt seep in here but at
3 49 nvidia's newest real-time ray
tracing accelerator is a cool hondo more
than its direct predecessor 60 tier card
anywho like the gtx 1070 we are down to
one 8-pin pci express power connector
and while our founders edition is still
rocking the new rtx style dual fan
cooler design we're treated to a smaller
lighter card overall that on the surface
looks a lot friendlier to small form
factors than his bigger brothers
in practice though this shorter pcb
design ends up being less helpful than
you'd think thanks to the rear position
of the pci express power connector
bummer
partner boards don't have to end up that
way though so all that really matters
about our founders edition is how it
performs
since launching two uproarious applause
rtx ray tracing and deep learning super
sampling anti-aliasing have been hot new
features announced for dozens of games
so
we should have plenty to look at now
that it's been on the market for several
months
rats that was more salt there wasn't it
but it's okay it's okay at least we have
something to look at now the shadow of
the tomb raider team's only birthday
present to me ended up being empty
promises but battlefield 5 and final
fantasy xv respectively had support for
these features though a new card
supporting them doesn't tell us much
that we didn't already know our fps is
roughly halved for the privilege of
turning rtx on which in this case
unfortunately takes a gpu that is
capable of playable frame rates at 4k
medium settings and drops us to 1080p is
the difference between 1080p and 4k that
noticeable
maybe not so much like we're really in
the heat of battle but as we discussed
in our recent video on resolution versus
frame rate the inability to run at
greater than 60 fps is going to put you
at a competitive disadvantage in
competitive games and that difference in
resolution is noticeable in sightseeing
titles as for dlss it performs pretty
well
but
it's locked at 4k
which means that this card translates to
a passable score in the final fantasy 15
benchmark it's not a great benchmark but
it does show us a pretty representative
performance difference between taa and
dlss
now whether or not you like the lss
anyway and the shimmering that it
retains on thin edges versus taa
that's another story on to more
traditional gaming scenarios the rtx
2060 runs significantly faster than the
gtx 1070 a pretty solid place to be
considering its similar specs and launch
price directx 12 in particular
exemplifies the improvements to
asynchronous compute that turing brings
to the table and as a result we've got a
decent uplift pretty much across the
board
and the rtx 2060s prospects improve even
further in our productivity suite where
it beats out the gtx 1070 by a
significant margin in luxmark and for
that matter actually most workstation
tasks
budget workstation use actually might be
this card's calling especially when you
look at its performance across all but
one test in specuperf
now while we didn't run any deep
learning tests today armchair ai
researchers should directly benefit from
the tensor course and the fact that the
geforce rtx 2060 is the cheapest card
that has them it should come as no
surprise though but with all this tech
packed into it power consumption is up
along with thermal output showing us
exactly why the card still rocks the
dense fin arrangement and dual fan
cooler design it's not terrible though
because the thing about power and
thermals is that you always have to look
at it relatively and amd's closest
performance competitor vega
isn't even in the same ballpark
helping matters further partner cards
will probably have some interesting
board layouts and cooling solutions that
should make this a very versatile little
gpu
with all of that in mind
who exactly is the rtx 2064 well at risk
of sounding negative for the life of me
i can't think of a reason to use its
premiere feature you know the one that's
printed several times on the card
i mean even at medium settings it still
halves your frame rate which is
unacceptable for a competitive shooter
like battlefield 5 especially if you use
a high refresh rate monitor
and yes dlss is faster than taa but that
assumes that a 6 gig card can run future
supported games in 4k
well enough to even use the feature
as for traditional rendering well it's
faster than a gtx 1070 at a similar
launch price
but
then you're paying a hundred dollar
premium on a 60 series card compared to
the previous 60 series anyway just for
the privilege of that rtx badge that
you're not using so the real conclusion
here seems to be the one that we haven't
been given the information to draw and
that's that you should buy the rumored
upcoming rtx list gtx 1160 that was
leaked with otherwise identical specs
now workstation performance seems really
promising at first but the 1160 should
come with the same benefits there as
well
unless you're into deep learning
which leaves us today then with a card
that occupies a tidy little
decent gaming and also light workstation
use niche until nvidia undermines its
own product with a lower priced
alternative so
buy it quickly then to ensure that it's
not irrelevant by the time it arrives oh
but buy the right version because rumor
has it there's three different memory
configurations across three different
capacities so
your mileage may vary
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes in
design business technology and more and
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to high quality classes on
must-know topics so you can improve your
skills
skill that's right in the name unlock
new opportunities and do the work that
you love one of our editors taryn has
been using skillshare a bunch he's done
courses on logo design mastering adobe
illustrator and he's gone through duncan
rogoff's mastering adobe after effects
course it's more affordable than most
learning platforms out there with an
annual subscription coming in at less
than ten dollars a month and the first
500 people that's you and you and you
you and you i can't do this 500 times
but 500 people to use the promo link in
the description will get their first two
months for free so go check it out
so thanks for watching guys if you
disliked this video you can hit that
button if you liked it hit like get
subscribed or maybe consider checking
out where to buy the stuff we featured
at the link in the video description
also down there is our overhauled merch
store which has so many cool new designs
at least two in a variety of colors
including this one
and our community forum which you should
totally join